what I think that's what that was you
don't always have to overlapping circles
in this space we have three so we can go
ahead and draw all of those what I'm
going to do is first we're just feeling
some numbers so we know it went like
that and then we're going to have a look
at what it is that this represents so
there's then we got some numbers I'd
really appreciate it if as I go I think
that's about why you've got to care of
that I think would be really helpful if
you turn your books because for me a
diagram hopefully this is already right
a diagram is not just a tool for
communicating for to someone else it's
also tool for constructing your own
thoughts it's why so often when you've
been doing geometry problems in the past
you look at a problem if you can't solve
it but then as you draw it yourself in
your book like oh I get it now these the
angles of these are the sides at home so
the very act of creating it I would
encourage as much as possible all right
once you've done so let's start I pack
these questions together understand what
the situation means it says this Venn
diagram shows the results of survey how
people how people can get how they get
to work okay so the CB and TV stand for
car bus and train so the first version
is how many people participated in the
survey now we have this diagram right
these numbers represent how many people
fit in each section so if I want to know
how many people in total participate in
the survey what I do any covers just
going to take the tow you okay so go
ahead on your water welcome to use your
calculator easy for your life is
necessary I'll give you saying really
think others addemup I think it's 100
total equals a hundred and it'd be good
if you can double check that yourself
just so we can be convinced from around
okay now you can see says after that
based on that 100 can we get driven to
some more detail right so it says how do
you people used all three methods bus
and then even italicize --is and train
give an example or give an explanation
on how this happened so before we do to
count how can that happen that someone
has to use a car and a bus and train to
get to work this is actually really how
I often get it's this especially now
that we have like train stations hidden
in our area so I will drive to a factory
because under the day so I Drive to the
program I'll Drive there get on the
Metro and then once I get into the city
to get to something more specific like
say after doing it some university that
doesn't have a train station so then
I'll catch a bus ok so that's how it can
happen maybe you would have ducked down
something to ensure that invention to
find a puppy can you now as you're
writing back look at the diagram you
join and tell me which part of the Venn
diagram is that group of people
it's the what's the number but it's the
fine but you took me fine because it's
the overlap or another one we might use
is the intersection between car and bus
and train in other words you've got to
be in all three circles at the same time
so I guess what I would say is calm bus
and trainer that's yeah we already just
told three hand that way ok so now we've
got a handle on how the situation is
coming here's where the probability
comes in so you can see what Part C asks
you calculate probability of selecting a
person from this survey who travels by
and then they give you a whole bunch of
different scenario so let's just go
through a couple of in all let you have
a go at some point your own pas once is
currently or button so it might help I'm
sorry Mitch massive colors in my
to school this is two different groups
of people right there's the car only
people in the bus ugly people which
number is the car oh very good 27 so you
can see it's in that numbers in the car
so go but it doesn't overlap with any of
the others so I've got back so therefore
we're calculating probability just like
when you're talking about tree diagrams
and stuff like that when you see the
word or what's the operations goes are
the treatments is a modification or
reserve it's going to be addition isn't
it so when you see the word before
you're going to be adding together
rather than multiplying so the 27th 2011
the probability of a car only or
certainly that's going to be equal to 27
plus F of E thank you very much
and then what's simplest it's 100
because I placed no restriction on who I
might ask in this situation it could be
anyone on the page so there's the
probability and you could have gosh
lissa as a percentage if you want 38
percent real quick I'm not going to do
years with you just will make sure
you're on my track when you look at Part
two it just says car and train car and
train now I'm going to give it a
different color out because diagrams
rapidly getting quite busy green will do
car and training so in this case I'm
looking for a particular group of people
that and means there's a bootable app
involved over laptop it's gonna be all
this 20 is definitely in this circle and
in this circle so I'll go now but
there's actually another number that's
also between motor circles which times
that it's the five that you mentioned
before earlier right these people that
you're retiring train innovate and
there's no word that indicates that
they're not allowed to take a bus it
doesn't say car and train only that's
actually the next part so you got this -
not this go ahead and you can again this
your problem
let me let you have a go at finishing -
doing three four and also Part D how'd
it go of those and then we'll close back
together when we get to part probability
of selecting someone who took car and
train but remember now we have to learn
early so what's different between talk
to and plus three what changed agenda
baby it's a group you two have to
exclude Michael you take me out the most
people right because you're like you
don't allow that what only excludes the
bus people sorry the story so now
probably gonna be it's not 25 over 100
is 20 over 100 which of course you can
simplify to be equally okay very good
and at this last point the probability
taking the bus and not the train so
which people is this you have to think a
little carefully thank you does anyone
feel confident and they can talk us
through not assistant Omar if told us
through how they came up with in number
two and just the 11 in the talk to the
you can put the 5 on the 4 cos bigotry
ok very good
fantastic so let's think about you talk
about four numbers in there how much
check each one two
so you said the 11 of the 12 thumbs up
because there was people right the
reason we haven't included their five in
the floor was wagon there was a
dignitary yeah very good so they're in
that area that we want to exclude so
therefore 12 plus 11 gives us 23 over
sorry under 23 and then again it's out
off 100 and you can see for all four of
these that we just did we always said
out of 100 because we decided to write
through the get-go but there are hundred
people in the situation but that's what
party dippers have a look at women it's
a bit of a of a bubble mouthful so take
your time with it a person is chosen at
random
now please mom this race carefully in
fact if you've got a highlighter I would
encourage you to get down right now and
highlight this phrase it's about it says
chosen at random for all he's the Prince
of my life the people who travel by car
or train
but no buffs just higher and higher
phrase it is a mouthful but that's what
highlighting the people will be
traveling by car will train early but
robots and then they ask the question
what's the probability to the person
travels by column only okay because it
says a person chosen from that area
right this is kind of what we would call
conditional probability right so we're
applying a condition we're saying you
know what I'm not gonna let you choose
from any of them I'm restricting you now
quite closely you can only choose from
some subsets of this okay now I want you
to help you work out what are the
subsets that are okay well maybe it's
easier to answer the other way which the
people are going to exclude so okay it
says but not bus so should we just like
a raise every number if you do you feel
like that'd be the right way to go so
there's four numbers we just considered
for this question right the 12 11 to 5
and the for this one reason why hey to
have your a diagram right for the
purposes of this question I'm just going
to forget the basis because for with
regard to Part D I'll move the allowed
to choose from everyone who is left off
line does that make sense
I had to exclude all those people okay
and then I say what's the poverty to the
pencil person traveling by car only so
when I say the probability that I've
calculated which other people travel by
car only then we'll be saying out of
whatever my sample space is now changes
the longer 100 ways the museum
especially a very good so this change
sample space of course makes it far more
likely because I've excluded 7 people
from the situation last little piece and
I think if you do these moles again a
party says if a hundred and ten people
actually touches
in the survey so we thought it was 100
from the beginning right but then they
say you know what you missed him
what extra information will be needed on
the diagram that's it yeah so whoever
those 10 were I guess they don't fit in
the information we've already got so
we're going to put them on the outside
facing them so we can conclude they
didn't take part or mussels what ramp